doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is finally here and it's a way
different movie than people were
expecting for one thing doctor strange
doesn't feel like the main character
here so who is
warning spoilers ahead at this point
savvy fans of the mcu know not to take
trailers seriously studios don't want
audiences to figure out the movies in
advance so filling trailers up with fake
outs has become a common practice from
editing characters out of scenes to
using dialogue or shots that don't even
make it into the final theatrical cut
the people who market these movies will
do just about anything to lie to fans
about how the actual film takes shape
the same is once again proven true for
marvel studios latest theatrical release
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness here's every time the trailers
lied to us
we should tell him the truth
the teaser and official trailer for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness strongly implied that the events
of the movie occur as a result of doctor
strange's spell gone wrong from
spider-man no way home or that strange
might attempt another spell that
shatters the border between realities in
his solo movie this proved to be a total
misdirect since the inciting incident
for this film isn't a doctor strange
spell of any kind marvel studios
executive kevin feige noted at the
film's world premiere the final episode
of loki provides the singular event that
makes the problems in the multiverse
possible if anything wanda meddles more
in the multiverse to start the movie
than strange himself as she desperately
searches for a way into a universe where
she can live in peace with her children
the film's teaser trailer uses lines
from the most recent spider-man movie to
imply that this film's events result
from all the different spider-man
characters crashing into earth 616.
again that's not the case strange only
gets involved after america chavez falls
right into his lap with a dead alternate
version of himself and a monster sent by
wanda in hot pursuit the first dr
strange movie distinctly sets up carl
mordo as strange's main adversary after
dormammu and cassilius are defeated
mordo of course does appear in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness but
not at all in the way fans expected
without context trailers for the movie
certainly make it seem as if strange
causes irreparable harm to the main mcu
universe inciting mordo to re-emerge and
punish his ex-friend for the so-called
desecration of reality in the finished
movie strange only meets mordo again
after traveling to earth 838 with
america and seeking out that universe's
sorcerer supreme mordo who works with
the illuminati the illuminati explained
to strange that they killed their
universe's version of strange after the
defeat of thanos because he was such a
liability for the stability of the
multiverse while the illuminati's
emergence makes for an interesting
sequence strange and america spend
little time with them wanda tears the
illuminati charles xavier and reed
richards included to shreds with
relative ease all in all patrick
stewart's screen time in the movie is
barely longer than the trailers
themselves
that doesn't seem fair aside from
strange and wanda america chavez may
receive the third most amount of screen
time of any character by the end of the
film's 126 minute run time audiences may
not have guessed that from trailers
though america is largely seen in the
background of course marvel studios and
disney likely had their reasons for
holding back this brand new character
america's powers and the details of how
she meets strange and wong in the first
place are spoiler heavy additionally
this movie is america's initiation to
the mcu casual moviegoers catching the
trailer probably don't even recognize
the character even so america makes for
a dominating force in the movie as her
powers make her the only known person
across the multiverse capable of
shifting herself between realms wanda
and strange both use the darkhold to
dreamwalk in other universes through
other versions of themselves but they
need america with them to make a
physical leap by the film's end america
takes control of her multiverse hopping
abilities and even finds a temporary
home at comtaj in earth 616. the
character seems like an important one
who will likely play a significant role
in mcu projects to come you wouldn't
know it by the trailers though check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the marvel
cinematic universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]